new details this morning on one of the
deadliest days for the fbi in nearly 35
years
agents carried the body of one of the
fallen into a medical examiner's office
yesterday
after an ambush that left two agents
dead and three others were hurt
forty-three-year-old laura
schwarzenberger had been with the fbi
for 16 years
thirty-six-year-old daniel alfin joined
in 2009.
now both of these fallen agents
specialized in crimes against children
manuel bajorkas is in sunrise florida
where the gunman reportedly looked
through his doorbell camera
before just opening fire manuel good
morning to you such a terrible story
it really is gail good morning and one
day after the shooting special teams
remain here on the scene trying to piece
together
exactly what led up to it what the
agents may have known about the suspect
going in
and how the gunman could have known they
were coming
[Music]
squad operation was multi gun traffic
from
five pages at this time the south
florida sun sentinel reports the fbi
team came under fire
before they had a chance to enter the
apartment where they were serving a
warrant
related to child pornography tuesday
they were valuable members
of the fbi and will forever be heroes
the fbi says slain agents daniel alfin
and laura schwarzenberger were very
involved in their community
sextortion is a form of sexual
exploitation
agent schwarzenberger appeared on local
television and visited area schools
teaching children how to avoid predators
that they had great
professional reputations will make their
memory even more powerful
stephanie douglas knows the perils all
too well she's a retired fbi agent
she says the shooting highlights the
dangers law enforcement officers face
when serving warrants and that
investigators will look meticulously at
how this one was planned
you really can't anticipate what you're
going to receive on the
other end of that door the suspect's
reported use of a doorbell camera before
the shooting
is a tactic known to the fbi back in
2017
the fbi sent out a report detailing how
cameras could be used by criminals
to see who's approaching
tuesday's shooting happened just 30
miles from another deadly incident for
the fbi
an april 1986 shootout that killed two
agents
douglas says the agency found lessons
there to better train agents
and will do the same with this tragedy
the lessons that will be learned from
this will be shared with agents in the
future one
injured agent was treated here at the
scene and released two others remain in
the hospital this morning in stable
condition the agency said
it will not release the name of the
gunman until his family has been
notified
anthony manuel thank you